alors je crois que les roumains banques
essentiellement de médicaments nous
avons été mois jean-françois hoffman le
cameraman et hervé gasparini le preneur
de son et est voir dans un hôpital pour
enfants
ce manque de médicaments
liberté liberté habache a touché ce coup
qu'il soit jugé pour le sang versé nous
sommes d'azur joue poste frontière avec
la bulgarie la mission humanitaire du
gouvernement français avec à sa tête
bernard kouchner vient de pénétrer en
territoire roumain sous les acclamations
de jeunes manifestants georgiou ou la
veille 15 personnes civiles et
militaires ont été tués par les agents
de la terrible securitate 60 km vivement
l'arrivée à bucarest une foule en liesse
l'aide française et avant tout médical
dans ses vues 70 hommes samu croire un
tipi ville il apporte des médicaments
tipl car c'est ce qui manque le plus
aurum exemple dans cet hôpital pour
enfants solidement gardés par l'armée
régulière
ici on redoute l'action isolée de francs
tireurs dans ce service de réanimation
angel à 6 ans elle vient de perdre un
sans doute l'une des plus jeunes
victimes de l'insurrection
frappé par une balle dans le ventre et
par des terroristes qu'ils continuent à
vanter la population sur leurs élus qui
l'entourent quel coin de but à sept
jours des vendanges qui a lutté contre
le terroriste qui a reçu deux balles
les infirmières travaillent sans relâche
depuis quatre jours avec les moyens du
bord
ici on manque de matériel et de
médicaments
en ce moment c'est sans l'assistance
d'un anesthésique d'analgésie parce que
il ya un grand crac itd mal acquis et
souffrir physiquement psychiquement qui
sont choqués à cause de ces tragiques
événements des événements qui auront
marqué la jeune génération qui n'a
jamais rien connu d'autre que ce régime
avant on pouvait rien faire si je
l'avais glienicke je ne pouvais pas le
dire aux autres à l'hôpital
chacun devait être un espion yes c'est
pas mauvais je pense que nous pouvons
faire des choses merveilleuses ici pour
les roumains ce sera le premier noël en
liberté un sapin déposé à l'entrée de
l'hôpital
à ses pieds des bougies à la mémoire des
victimes du régime de ceausescu
voilà ce qu'on peut donc vous dire ici
ce soir en direct de bus karen moi bien
sûr et qu'on va continuer au tour de la
télévision
ici à l'ambassade de france nous avons
aussi essuyé quelques tirs
et bien je vous donne rendez vous dans
nos prochaines éditions de mardi
télématin à 13h et puis bien sûr 20h 23h
bien bien entendu françoise comme vous
nous l'indiqué à l'instant nos
installations de direction maintenant
sur p